consider the functions f and g with the
graphs shown below if capital g of x is
equal to lowercase g of lowercase f of x
what is the value of capital g prime of
2.5 so g of x is a composition of g and
f so it's g of f of x or lowercase g of
f of x and they don't graph capital g of
x here they just give us the graphs of
lowercase g of x and lowercase f of x
this is the graph of lowercase f of x
this is a graph of lowercase g of x
so let's just try to think how we could
evaluate this and then see if they've
given us the right information here
so let me just rewrite a lot of what
they've already told us they've already
told us that capital g of x
is equal to
lowercase g
of
f x
so if we wanted to take the derivative
of capital g of x and we do want to
think about what the derivative of
capital g of x is because they want us
to evaluate the derivative at at x is
equal to 2.5 so let's do that let's take
the derivative of both sides of this
so if we
take the derivative of the left hand
side we end up with
g
prime
of x
and on the derivative on the right hand
side since we have a composition here of
two functions we would apply the chain
rule so this is going to be the
derivative of g
with respect to f so we could write that
as g
prime
of f of x
g prime of f of x times the derivative
of f with respect to x so times
f prime
of x
so if we want to evaluate what g prime
of 2.5 is then every place we see an x
here we have to store a 2.5 in there so
let's try to do that
so g prime
g prime of and i'll do this in white so
it sticks out g prime of 2.5
is going to be equal to
lowercase
lowercase g prime
of
f of
f
of
2.5
f of 2.5
times
f prime
of 2.5
f prime of 2.5
so let's think about what these would
evaluate to what is f of 2.5
well when x is equal to 2.5
i'm just in a color you can actually see
when x is equal to 2.5 our function here
is equal to 1.
so f of 2.5 so we know that f of 2.5 is
equal to 1.
let me write that down f of 2.5 is equal
to 1.
and we also need to figure out what f
prime of 2.5 is
so f
let me write it this way
f prime
f prime of 2.5 is equal to
now what is f prime of 2.5 that's just
essentially the slope of the tangent
line
at the function when x is equal to 2.5
so it's really just the slope
right over here
and at least right over this part of the
function where it's actually a line and
the slope is actually very easy to spot
out if we were to go from this point to
this point here and i'm just picking
those points because those are on kind
of integer valued coordinates we see
we see that for every
for every 3 that we run we go up 2
or that we rise to for every three that
we run or that our change in y over
change in x is two
over three so the slope
the slope of the function right over
there is two thirds
so this is equal to
two-thirds and so we can substitute back
in here f of 2.5 is equal to
one and this right over here is equal to
two-thirds now we're not done yet now we
have to evaluate what is g prime
of one
so when x is equal to one this is the
function g we're not evaluating g of one
we're evaluating g prime of one so what
is the slope of the line here well our
change in y over change in x is two over
one
if we go one in the horizontal direction
we go up two in the vertical direction
change in y over change in x is two
over one so g prime let me write this
down
g
prime
of 1
g prime of 1
is equal to
is equal to 2. so this whole thing
evaluates to 2
and so this simplifies let me scratch
that out this simplifies to 2 times 2 3
which is equal to 4 thirds so we could
write g prime
of 2.5
of 2.5 is equal to four-thirds and this
is a pretty neat problem because we
didn't get to see the actual function
definition from g of x but just using
the chain rule and the information
they're giving us we were able to figure
out what the value of this derivative is
when x is equal to 2.5